we will not be sending US troops back
into combat in Iraq but I have asked my
national security team to prepare a
range of other options that could help
support Iraq security forces and i'll be
reviewing those options in the days
ahead the United States will do our part
but understand that ultimately it's up
to the Iraqis as a sovereign nation to
solve their problems the United States
has poured a lot of money into these
Iraqi security forces and we devoted a
lot of training to Iraqi security forces
the fact that they are not willing to
stand and fight and defend their posts
against admittedly hardened terrorists
but not terrorists who are overwhelming
in numbers indicates that there's a
problem with morale there's a problem in
terms of commitment and ultimately
that's rooted in the political problems
that have plagued the country for a very
long time